mercredi dernier jabès hadas à
enfourcher sa bicyclette pour se rendre
au travail
mais en cours de route il s'est fait
arrêter par un policier même si son vélo
étaient munies de bandes réfléchissantes
sur la fourche de réflecteurs sur les
pédales les daims phares clignotants à
l'arrière il ne comportait pas de
réflecteurs avant et arrière comme l'
oblige le code de la sécurité routière
il est venu avec trois contraventions
ont pour chaque réflecteurs puis pour
les frères et la facture est salée 381 $
pour payer avec un vélo qui vaut même
pas de champ d'horreur c'est ridicule
j'trouve ça en abus de pouvoir ça depuis
l'entrée en vigueur du nouveau code de
la sécurité routière
l'amendé passé de 30 à 80 dollars plus
les frais on en aurait mis en avant un
en arrière
la pdg de vélo québec déplore cet
incident on donne deux contraventions
pour 2 réflecteurs manquait quand même
je trouve c'est vraiment viser ça prend
6 réflecteurs son vélo est ce qu'on va
donner six contraventions à 127 dollars
à quelqu'un qui a passé réflecteurs sur
son vélo alors qu'ils roulaient en plein
jour
c'est ce les aigles vélo québec s'oppose
aussi à l'augmentation de 4 100 % du
prix des contraventions que vous brûler
un feu rouge à vélo et qui vous manquent
réflecteurs sur votre vélo en plein jeu
semaine cris 125 $ avec les crèmes ou
autre c'est totalement abusif
voici donc ce qu'il vous faut sur votre
vélo en plus des réflecteurs avant et
arrière un réflecteur au rayon avant et
arrière ou encore des pneus aux flancs
réfléchissant ou des bandes
réfléchissantes sur les fourches
ajoutez à cela les réflecteurs aux
pédales ou des bandes réfléchissantes
aux chevilles ou aux chaussures
les femmes sont aussi obligatoires le
soir jabès hadas contestera ces
contraventions ici valérie michaela
bayne radio canada montréal